the batgirl movie as we all know is
canceled the people deserve a batgirl
movie warner brothers did us dirty all
people need is to see a little fan-made
trailer that gives them the spark of
inspiration and the hope is that we can
do with this giant corporation couldn't
and that is get people excited about
batgirl
holy cancellation batman studio
executives have done what comic villains
have tried to do for years they
apparently killed batgirl wb and dc
they're [ __ ] idiots warner brothers
is axing its upcoming batgirl film what
are they thinking no one will ever see
what has now become a very expensive
mistake
the batgirl movie as we all know is
canceled
but the whole thing was shot and there's
also like a ton of behind the scenes set
photography that was taken
showing some really complex setups so in
this league footage we've got a wicked
like chase scene on top of a fire truck
brendan frazier as firefly the villain
is fighting a firefighter he's like
swinging his fireman axe at him batgirl
is riding behind on a motorbike it looks
really cool
there's so many awesome like set pieces
here what has been released for this
officially besides the bts as far as i
know there was actually only one
official photo of batgirl released by
warner brothers but no official teaser
has been released no trailer they
brought out brendan fraser they gave him
two flame throwers put them on a fire
truck and they have the gall they have
the audacity to delete the movie in the
middle of the fraser sands
they decide to just scrap it dude and
then michael keaton what do they have
against bats and girls the people
deserve a batgirl movie warner brothers
did us dirty we need to recreate batgirl
and and deliver it to the people when
the opening scene of deadpool was leaked
it caused a
huge uproar in the internet and people
demanded that this movie
be made and it did so maybe all people
need is to see a little fan-made trailer
that gives them the spark of inspiration
maybe at the end of this all they will
listen to the people they will listen to
our call and release this tiny little 90
million movie that they made and then
threw in the trash
so we've done our research we have
looked at the entirety of the 11 minutes
of behind the scenes for batgirl which
is pretty much the only footage that
exists there's not a whole lot to work
with here this is unlike any other
corridor crew video it's not something
like spider-man rated r where you can
simply pull a bunch of footage from
pre-existing movies we don't have the
movie batgirl to use so really all we
can use this behind the scenes footage
for is reference as to what the movie
might look like and to be able to
actually piece together everything to
make a convincing trailer i've made a
list for you
that's a list
and the first thing we need on the list
is a batgirl batgirl of course we need a
batgirl that's the name of the movie we
don't have leslie grace because she's
not available we asked but we do have
jordan coleman hi
she looks a hell of a lot like leslie
grace i've always wanted to be a
superhero do i get to save people
you get to save
an entire franchise
okay
so we've got a barbara gordon but we
don't have a costume and well this
movie's not out so it's not like we can
just buy one online it's not that easy
we have to make it ourselves and for
that we're going to call upon the
services and talents of ren and fenner
runner
hey fenner oh what's going on with the
lights oh
it's just trying to get in the mood dude
you can get the light if you want
kind of stressed we need to make sure
that these helmets look good on camera
we're trying to emulate that feature
film quality and make this look like the
real batgirl trailer we can't just order
some halloween costume so instead of
ordering these back howls online
we decided to make them from scratch
first up we're gonna need a photo scan
jordan coleman's entire head will be
able to bring our 3d photo scan into
blender i'm going to model the cowl
around her photoscanned head and then
we'll have to 3d print this thing ren
has a brand new 3d printer with a giant
print bed that should be able to fit the
entire cowl in there printed it in pink
is because that was the only filament i
had enough filament for
should we see if it fits i think we
should i think it might be smaller
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to go into the morning meeting
with that
two other things that may be filming
this week that we can chat about is
start of the batgirl photography so now
that we know that the cowl fits rena is
going to print us out a few of them so i
can make a couple different versions of
this cowl for one of these i'm going to
cover the rough spots with bondo and
sand it down so it's our nice smooth
hero prop i'm also going to turn one of
our damaged prints into kind of a
damaged version of the helmet for a you
know special little moody moment in our
trailer
it's coming together once they're
painted we're going to need a vinyl wrap
to replicate the carbon fiber look of
the actual batgirl helmet oh my god
there's carbon fiber i think this means
the mask will be indestructible so i've
never actually done a vinyl wrap before
but i'm pretty stoked on the final
product and so is jordan
it seriously looks so good on camera
so we're done with the cowls and they
look great but that's not the only part
of the costume we're making from scratch
matt and jordan spent a ton of time
sourcing different pieces of this
costume there's a custom cape there's
some awesome gold shiny boots but my
personal favorite is they actually
printed out a custom crest and they got
a tailor to actually stitch on that
background logo right onto the jacket so
now that our costume is complete we can
finally bring this version of back over
life
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have a perfect batgirl and the
costume it works it's all looking
beautiful but we can't just have a
superhero we gotta have a villain in
there from our behind the scenes
reference we know that that villain is
firefly brendan frazier was in the
middle of a comeback man he was on the
top of his game and he was about to be a
villain the main villain in a very big
blockbuster action movie but they canned
it they scrapped him
they left him to the side of the road
crying but i tell you what we're going
to pick them up from the side of the
road put them in our van and put them in
our batgirl trailer so i watched a ton
of his new movies and clips from them
and i finally found something from a
movie that no one has seen where he's
monologuing about masks what is it with
people you know it's like
they're always wearing masks the reason
why this monologue works super well is
because it's something that everyone
expects to see in a trailer they want
that like brooding dark villain
monologue so now we have a really sweet
monologue from brendan fraser out of the
costume but we still need that costume
to really sell this so we're gonna call
upon the talents of jordan and fenner so
i was tasked with actually building the
firefly costume from the ground up all
we really have is some loose bts
photography from people who were around
when they were shooting it obviously
with someone who's this complex with
flame throwers on his hands and stuff
like that we're not gonna go the
practical route right we're not gonna go
the route of actually building this
costume from the ground up in real life
so really that leaves us to create only
the chest piece and of course the actual
helmet itself you know we can see the
big eyes with the crossbars over the top
kind of like an old diver helmet you can
see that it's like some sort of leather
or fabric and you get a good idea of
like the earpiece and the mouthpiece and
stuff like that so those are the
important elements that we need to hit
so once we have all these elements
completed in cg we're free to slap them
on any footage we can find that kind of
looks like our base firefly
so now that jordan's built out this
awesome firefly asset we have basically
our full costume luckily for us matt
found this awesome flamethrower dude on
storyblocks he's got the dual
flamethrowers like firefly scout on this
sweet trenchcoat basically what we're
gonna do is take the awesome assets the
jordans created light them up in blender
track them on and then light the scene
where i'm basically placing point lights
where the fire is so we actually get
this nice like raking light and shadows
on the costume so once all the lighting
is complete on this and i've got the
whole asset track to our stock footage i
hit render on this and i bring it to new
now that we've got our render in nuke we
basically have to prep our background
plate of our stock footage so i
basically just warped this guy's head
down he's got this weird little tiny
head now but what that does is it gives
us this natural fall off of like the
shoulders going into the helmet and it
saves us a ton of time doing paint work
stepping down through our tree we then
are adding our beauty pass here adding
in a bunch of different like smoke
elements embers that sort of thing after
that chromatic aberration crazy
distortion around the edges and just all
sorts of nice flaring and kind of
different lens elements so it's only 34
frames but it's worth it to add in that
extra detail and attention that makes it
look like it's a shot that could have
come out of an actual hollywood studio
now what is the point of having firefly
if we don't have any fire our idea a la
dark knight was to light up a giant
pyramid of cache joker style everything
burns
it's a problem you can't really handle
with stock footage if you want accurate
shadows and reflections being cast off
the pile of money so instead we
generated a giant procedural pyramid of
cash sprinkled some money over the top
of it to add some natural randomness to
the pile and then churned out a big old
blaze in fire using the axiom solver
inside of houdini we wanted to send out
brendan fraser's performance in a blaze
of glory and only a giant pirate of
burning cash can do that for our boy
it's like the entire theme
behind this movie is fire fire is bad
fire is burning well guess what fire is
cleansing and we are gonna burn down
more right now
not for me w b
not for me
w b
not for me
w b
naught
not for me
wb
not for me
okay i'm starting to assemble some of
these assets into a timeline and it's
really starting to flow this is exciting
hold on jake's calling me what's going
on jake what are you doing right now i
mean i'm just assembling batgirl uh it's
gonna be a long haul okay uh i left
something on your desk this morning um
check check around you let me know if
you find it hold on let's go did you you
put it on my chair i was sitting on it
the whole time okay i found it okay
those are a pair of raycon everyday
earbuds courtesy of today's sponsor
raycon they're gonna make you look feel
and sound better than ever before wow
i've always dreamed of listening to my
sick beats with raycon earbuds they're
not for you they're for batgirl we have
to reshoot everything with raycons in
batgirl's ears there's gotta be a way to
offer a premium wireless earbud for
about half the cost of other premium
wireless earbuds out there on the market
there's got to be a way to get an
optimized gel tip for the perfect in-ear
fit of an earbud yeah well yeah i guess
that would be a concern if she also
listens to sick beats which of course
she does they also offer eight hours of
play time and a 32-hour battery life you
don't have to take my word for it okay
matt think of the over 48 000 5 star
reviews that raycon everyday earbuds
have
just go to byraycon.com corridor
and you'll get 15 off your purchase
that's by raycon.com corridor crew for
15 off your purchase it's a good
it is a good deal
click the link in the description below
if you're interested in getting a pair
for yourself okay hit the link in the
description
all right i gotta go all right i'll see
you later matt
so we got a villain and we got a hero
but those two they gotta fight that's
something you expect to see in a
superhero trailer is some really sick
action and fight sequences but how are
we gonna do that well jordan coleman has
actually been training in martial arts
for a couple months now so i think she
has the chops to pull this off along
with some help this is the location that
we're looking at right now uh what do
y'all think of this cool it's cool right
yeah has some character to it a lot of
youtube history here so we are bringing
in a really talented fight coordinator
and a friend of corridor jaquan who's
going to choreograph a fight sequence
for us i'm very nervous
because i'm with a bunch of people who
do this for a living and it's just i
don't want to [ __ ] up and hurt people
and like they do this every day i'm so
scared
i really am it'll be good okay
the first step to this is pre-visiting
the fight i'll basically just film on my
phone all of the choreography that he's
designing and then we'll be able to
determine what the best framing for
these shots are and what is really going
to sell the impacts
after
many run-throughs she started doing it
faster and stronger and much better
thank you guys
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get it down
now it's time for cinema
we can't just create an action sequence
and a couple of cool costumes we need to
photograph this in a way that matches
big budget hollywood films and that's no
easy task when you have a very limited
budget and limited resources but it's
not impossible so the first step in
achieving like a big budget cinema feel
is the camera and the lenses we have
access to an ari alexa mini lf which is
what tons of big budget hollywood
blockbusters use to photograph their
films and we're using the same kind of
anamorphic lenses that they use on films
like the batman it photographs and
interacts with light differently than
most other lenses it's why movies have a
certain look to them but selling the
cinema look is not just about what
camera you use it is about what you put
in front of your camera we are trying to
mimic batgirl driving on the road and
the best way to do that is to get these
animated lights we have these titan
tubes that can animate a moving light
across and uh you know it's got them so
they're going to have probably different
color temperatures and colors on on
their streets so we got that going we
also have some other lights that we're
going to whip her with that are going to
really help sell that movement since
we're on a green screen but we can't
just shoot everything on a green screen
we also need some expensive looking
locations and we cannot afford any of
these locations so we're going to steal
them instead of pick up on the helipad
which is if
oh make it stop so we snuck up onto the
roof of a building in downtown l.a to
steal some shots of the city skyline and
i gotta tell you they ended up looking
incredible in this type of environment
the anamorphics really really shine you
can see why so many big budget films use
them but because this is shot at night
we still need to add some lights into
our scenes to light our subjects and
aputure made this possible by providing
us with some very portable easy to use
lights that are battery operated and we
could get onto the roof of the building
very easily but we don't have to steal
every location on this production for
other less expensive locations like our
street that we're going to be using
later we can up the production value by
adding a little extra flair to them one
thing hollywood movies do all the time
is they wet their streets down to give
it that reflective sheen so to my right
here you'll see the dry drought-ridden
streets of la and over to our left
we have the mean
dark
moist streets of gotham so we've been
wedding down the street and uh it looks
amazing on camera it's just gonna give
us that little you know cinematic push
over the finish line
my body is going through all these uh
i think they call it nerves anxiety the
stunt guys are here and they're just
they're so good at what they do they're
so calm this will be like the third time
i've practiced i guess and now we're
doing it today in costumes way different
like i can't really even
up like do an elbow as high because the
costume i don't want it to like rip and
like at all i want to make dark knight
as easy as possible and i just want to
nail all the moves
i'm sweating i'm a nervous wreck
all right
and three two one action
[Music]
all right cut it
like this is something i've always
wanted to do but now i totally
understand why actresses have stunt
bubbles
because i am completely out of breath
even though i feel like i'm working very
hard they make it look like i'm working
even harder much praise to them because
this is
very hard it's very fun but it's very
exhausting
so we now have a lot of cinematic appeal
on our trailer but i think we're missing
one vital cinematic moment the moody
rain shot
but we're going through a drought right
now so la never rains
however i can design a rain machine that
will give us the desired effect and mood
[Music]
did it work yes you look very upset
[Music]
this wouldn't be a comic book trailer if
it didn't have an extended universe
behind it and not just any universe the
dc universe we want to include a bunch
of the other superheroes in our trailer
and so to do that we have jordan look
we're not living in a vacuum all right
the dc universe
we're talking expansive open world
infinite possibilities warner brothers
has effectively discarded batgirl and
it's not right well who else have they
discarded ryan reynolds green lantern
we're bringing him back well we're not
actually going to bring him back but
we're going to bring his ring back also
cyborg they canceled his movie and it's
not right so we're going to bring these
characters back to the screen now
granted we're killing them we're killing
them off in the trailer
but we're raising awareness for
the the trampling that warner brothers
has done to our our beloved cast of
characters
so now we have all of the elements we
need to make a convincing cinematic
trailer but now we got to piece it all
together and it's going to be easy it's
just a walk in the park i'll just slap
some clips together and probably have a
lot of late nights and um cry a little
bit but it'll be all great because by
the end of it we're gonna have a
convincing trailer that we're gonna show
the team and then release to the world
and the hope is that we can do what this
giant corporation couldn't and that is
get people excited about batgirl
oh man we're about to watch a batgirl
trailer that is now in its final stages
and i'm so excited to show each and
every one of you because we put a ton of
work into it and jordan is joining us
remotely today because she's in atlanta
filming an actual movie are you excited
to see yourself on the big screen i'm
very excited it's one of those funny
things where it started with just this
idea of doing a trailer and it just
snowballed yeah anyway let's fricken
slap this thing on and see what happens
this isn't just some random murder
it's an extermination
dozens of witnesses all over gotham
no discernible pattern i can see
when the streets burn the corpses of our
favorite heroes
who can save us
hello gotham
batgirl here
firefly must be stopped
but i can't do it alone i don't exist
i'm not even here get it together man
we're all that's left and right here
right now
the universe needs you everybody's got a
mask on
i got one you got one
every now and then
it slips a little bit
there's good and there's evil and evil
must be punished
90 million dollars
up in flames the police have got it
wrong firefly was just a decoy
but if not him
then who
we're
the warner brothers and you're
a rider
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was super cool really sick footage
of that girl you guys got that looks
amazing so cinematic ridiculous this
looks incredible everybody did an
amazing job it's lit really well it's
shot really well jordan you did a really
good job playing batgirl that line on
the roof where pins are like hey batgirl
here is such a like actual movie
it's pretty sweet wait i just realized
it goes from three viewers to two when
we revealed that girl she's not the most
popular dc character
you did really good you made the look
happen you made the acting did the fight
scenes yeah it was i was stressed i
thought i was gonna poop myself when we
were out there well jordan you did a
phenomenal job especially with like such
a limited time to learn all that
choreography and yeah we literally
couldn't have done it without you at all
oh i had a blast it was so fun i gotta
say that the firefly 3d model is
indistinguishable from reality that's a
3d model
jesus christ i had no idea i thought
that was hard
to move from like a different movie or
something
yeah are you guys with me
is that supposed to be ezra miller
though that's ezra miller with like a
busted flash mask we wanted to flash in
there like a manic flash just destroying
the lot
[Laughter]
are those dick tracy warner brother guys
are they wearing like makeup
yes so ali sortwell did this makeup and
she did a phenomenal job as well so
thank you ali what other shout outs otm
on the mark media they provided us with
the cine gear that we needed to make
this as good as it could possibly be so
thank you guys and to all of the actual
filmmakers of batgirl it sucks that the
movie was canceled but hopefully this
can bring some levity to this crappy
situation
i am what i am
what do you guys think did they pull it
off did we make a batgirl trailer that's
worthy of the actual production and of
the hype let us know in the comments
below also if you want to see us use our
vfx filmmaking skills to take on any
other projects leave some ideas down
below thanks bye
consider subscribing